for the Hong Kong people use fine thing
against a giant we are fighting against
the Chinese cameras
yeah baby reach their powerful their
area on the walls
for those people that who want to
destroy the student movement including a
Chinese government including the triad
they work together so they beat up the
people here the usual handle means to
irritate to hear 8a and also to disturb
the movement but the organizer and the
student here they are very peaceful we
support long Marilyn action to find for
him opposite so lots of the people who
have been fitting up but they left of
the Italian you know so they all follow
the nonviolent principle and we use that
as a mobile weapon to fight for
democracy for the people of Hong Kong
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your app store now